hello if you have found the ideas i
discussed
interesting and useful perhaps you might
consider purchasing my recently released
book beyond order 12 more rules for life
available from penguin random house in
print
or audio format you could use the links
we provide below or
buy through amazon or at your local
bookstore
this new book beyond order provides what
i hope is a productive and interesting
walk through ideas that are both
philosophically and
sometimes spiritually meaningful as well
as being
immediately implementable and practical
beyond order can be read and understood
on its own
but also builds on the concepts that i
developed in my previous books
12 rules for life and before that
maps of meaning thanks for listening
and enjoy the podcast
[Music]
i'm pleased today to be talking to dr
ian mcgillcrist
i met him in 2018
um in london and we had the good fortune
to have a
relatively brief conversation which was
taped and put on youtube and
it was very productive and so now i get
to talk to him again
and hopefully for a longer period of
time um
ian is a psychiatrist dr mcgillcrist is
a psychologist
a psychiatrist a former fellow of all
souls college
oxford an associate fellow of green
templeton college oxford
he's lectured all over the world he's
published a number of scientific papers
he's most well known for his book the
master and his emissary and i think you
have a copy of that
i asked you to get that so that you
could show people
um the master and his emissary
the divided brain in the making of the
western world which is an analysis
of hemispheric specialization and its
philosophical and scientific
significance
um and he's working on a new book which
i have
and have started to read a long ways
into it at the moment called the matter
of things
which will be forthcoming at some point
in the future and
will shape some of our discussion today
he's published broadly scientifically
and publicly a
study of paintings on of subjects with
psychotic illnesses that's coming out i
believe
i'm planning that and a series and
also forthcoming a series of essays
about culture and the brain
so welcome thank you very much for
agreeing to talk to me
oh it's a huge pleasure jordan thank you
very much
so
one of the things i was rereading the
introduction to your new book
this morning and i was struck
by many different topics but i was
particularly interested in your
conception of attention
and so you talk about attention as
something that in some sense brings
things into being
i don't think that's a misreading of
your of your
of your writing and maybe i could get
you to expound on that a bit and
to tell me what you think attention is
because i've had a hell of a time
differentiating it from well from fluid
intelligence for example or from
consciousness
like it's a word that makes sense when
you hear it in the context of a bunch of
other words but when you extract it out
from that context and try to grip it
it falls apart in your grasp so
i think one could say that attention is
the way in which
the individual disposes his or her
attention
it's it's a disposition of one's
consciousness
so attention is how you dispose your
consciousness towards the world
and uh when i discovered when i was
researching
the master in his emissary the book
that's now 10 years old
i came across this fascinating thing
that one of the most
fundamental differences between the
hemispheres is their way of
attending and it didn't entirely hit me
at the time
how important it is but we can talk
about that
later but you were asking the rather
sort of interesting philosophical
question about how
attention helps to bring things into
being
and i think it does both generally and
rather particularly very particular
sense in the left hemisphere
generally what i mean is that how you
attend to the world
depends you know on that depends
what world you find the qualities of the
world
that comes to your attention is
determined by the quality of the
attention you bring to it
and
that's a very significant that's a very
significant statement
i was talking to someone the other day
who's somewhat theologically minded and
um he was also very interested in the
role that
attention played on in constituting the
world
i mean you pay attention to things that
you value
one way or another and what that means
is that the world tends to manifest
itself
in relationship to your value structure
and
that that's very troublesome idea
in some sense with regards to our
conceptions of the objective world
because
it's not easy to it's not easy to parse
out what's objective
when what manifests itself to you is
dependent
in large part on what you value it's
very complicated to sort that all out
well possibly very much later we can
come to the question
of what objective and subjective
mean and how one can
i think it's a mistaken dichotomy i
think one can
interpret the words in important ways
that give them meaning but i think
to think of the just being an objective
world out there
and a subjective world in here is one of
the problems with modern western
philosophy
but um to come back to the creation of
the world i was going to say that not
only does it sort of bring into the
world
the world that you know which is after
all by definition the only world you
will ever know
but it also changes who you are so the
quality of the attention
you pay changes you the attender
so it's a very profound difference and
in the
first book the master in his embassy one
of the things i was
expounding was how this business
of attention creates a whole distinct
world so the the hemispheres have have
evolved to to two different sets of
values you mentioned
values and it's very germane they have
different
reasons for existing and therefore have
different things they respond to
um and what
i have tried to explain in that book
is that this gives rise to a whole
way of seeing the world in the whole
world which is not just for the
individual but also
at times it becomes the way of looking
at the world for a whole culture
because of course when as individuals
never entirely distinct from our culture
we
partly created by our culture and make
it what it is
so it's a very fundamental thing well
you take
pains in in the master and his emissary
to to promote the idea or to call
attention to the idea
that something extremely mysterious is
going on
in relationship to hemispheric
specialization so
yeah it's a very ancient phenomenon
yes many creatures or most creatures
with developed nervous systems have
a bifurcated brain and yes
the the hemispheres differ substantially
in terms of their neuro
anatomical structure and the question
arises
why is it necessary assuming that that
differentiation of
structure reflects some profound
differentiation of function
why is it necessary to look at the world
so to speak
in two ways and why is it so necessary
that that
bifurcation is conserved across
evolutionary history
you'd think that one way would be
sufficient but it doesn't seem to be and
so the first question is why do you have
to look at the world in two ways
and the next question might be well what
what are those two ways
one of the things you outline that's
particularly fascinating to me
is that the right hemisphere seems to be
specialized
more for what you don't know well
whereas the left hemisphere is
specialized
more for what you do know and i've
sort of defined knowing pragmatically
um you know something if you undertake
an action
and the outcome is what you specified
and you don't know something if you
undertake an action and the outcome is
other than what you specified
and that sort of reflects that novelty
organization
um division that that
was goldberg i believe that that
originated that
that the neuropsychologist
well jordan you've raised a whole bunch
of points there so i need a little bit
of time to
to explain that um
first of all every neural network that
we know of
is asymmetrical going down to the very
most basic network that we know and the
most ancient one that we know
nematostelovectensis um a sea anemone
that is 700 million years old is already
asymmetrical in its
neural network and that's the earliest
neural network we know of
and it's true of insects it's true of
worms it's true you know all the way up
to
to human beings and the three questions
that really got me
going on this was if the brain is there
for
making connections and its power is
largely
lies in the question the connections it
can make why is it divided
down the middle whoppingly divided i
mean most people don't realize quite how
big this this differentiation is and if
they haven't actually seen a brain
um the second thing is why is it
asymmetrical
because if you just need to grow this
brain you'd grow it symmetrically the
skull that contains it is symmetrical
and the third thing is why is the
connection the principal connection
between the two hemispheres at the base
of the hemispheres
the corpus callosum why is it at least
as much if not more
in the service of inhibition than
facilitation
so it's as though there's something
really important about keeping two
things apart
now my my
hypothesis and it's just that is
that this results from something that
all creatures need to do
all creatures without exception need to
eat and not be eaten
they need to live and to manipulate
their environment to get food to catch
something to pick something up quickly
deftly to pick up a twig to build a nest
in other words for all the kind of
day-to-day stuff food shelter
they need to be able to manipulate the
world very
precisely but at the same time they must
pay
a precisely opposite kind of attention
which is sustained
vigilant open without presupposition
to as to what it may find and so on the
whole
uh the way in which this has been
addressed by
evolution is that there are two neuronal
masses that can
direct attention at the world and the
left hemisphere tends to specialize in
targeted precise attention
and the right hemisphere in a much
broader vigilant kind of attention which
actually sustains the being of the world
nothing about these tiny fragments that
are isolated disconnected meaningless
gives you any idea of their meaning it's
only when you see the broad picture and
you understand that they're not actually
things that go to be put together to
make that broad picture but things that
are isolated out of an already connected
picture
um so that's the basis of that
i just wanted to pick up your thing
about um
because i don't think it's quite right
to say that the left hemisphere is about
what you know and the rights what about
about what you don't know somebody i
can't remember who
um some philosopher said
that knowledge is what we're uncertain
of
uh things we're certain of are things
that we don't really know properly i
think
there's a good deal of truth in that the
left hemisphere
tends to jump to conclusions it's much
more quick and dirty than the right
hemisphere
the right hemisphere is the one that
says hang on wait a moment you may be
getting this wrong because it wants to
get things
quickly it's it's job is to manipulate
its job is to get it's to catch it's to
grab stuff it's the one that controls
the right hand that does all the
grabbing
so the left hemisphere tends to
certainty and it's very uncomfortable
when there's ambivalence
uh whereas you can't act
exactly whereas the right hemisphere
seems to appreciate the possibility
that we have to hold multiple views
multiple possibilities together
and so it has a quite different
take on reality it's more interested in
discovery and exploration rather than
capture the left-handers more interested
in capturing a thing that it thinks it
knows often
you know not in any deep way it's just
identified an object it needs
but to understand things the right
hemisphere is better and the idea of the
master and the emissary is
is i i won't go through the the myth of
it i've explained it so many times but
the basic idea is that the
master the right hemisphere knows that
it needs an atmosphere to do the sort of
functional administration
work so it's aware that the stuff that
it
mustn't get involved with and that it
can't know whereas the
left hemisphere knows everything as it
were in its eyes because
it only knows a tiny bit which is
explicit
and you know there it is in broad
daylight down in black and white
no uh no shades of meaning no nuances no
nothing implicit about it so it thinks
it knows it
and if you like the downfall of the left
hemisphere
and therefore if i would go of the
society the civilization
as it once was that we belong to is
that the left hemisphere doesn't know
what it is it doesn't know
it's you know it's you know the famous
thing the dunning-kruger effect
the the more you know the more you think
you don't know and the people who know
least think they know everything
uh it's a little it's not quite fair but
there's something of that about it
yeah but can i pick up something that
i touched on earlier we just do we were
talking about creating the world through
attention and i think that is
that is true um and there's a very big
question there about what i
mean by that do i mean just as you say
subjectively or objectively maybe we
should
perk that for the moment but um
i don't mean either in a very simple way
but what is fascinating
is that the right hemisphere as i say
knows that there are things that it's
not aware of
but the left hemisphere seems to take
the attitude that if it's not attending
to it it doesn't exist
this is very dramatic in clinical
neurology so
people who've had a right hemisphere
stroke
they not only as it were don't now pay
attention to something
but they deny that that thing ever
existed this
wonderful uh you know
very rich accounts of patience one of
the ones that i really like is a is a
experiment done by who was it uh biziyak
and luksati i think
back in the late 1970s where they got a
couple of highly educated people with
right hemisphere strokes
and they are they was in milan at the
time and they said you know
these these people lived in milan and
they said imagine you're standing in the
piazza del duomo in front of the
cathedral
and looking at the square describe all
the
the buildings in the square and they
would describe only the ones on the
right side that the left hemisphere only
pays attention to
whereas you know but i need to say for
the viewers that the right hemisphere
pays attention to both
halves of the world so when you have a
left hemisphere stroke the world is
relatively preserved globally
but after a right hemisphere stroke
you're only relying on this left
hemispheres interested in the bit of
space which it can manipulate the bit on
the right
so they named the buildings down the the
right hand side of the view of the
square they had then
and then the experiment asked them to go
to the other end of the square and look
at the cathedral facade and
name the buildings and this time they
named all the ones down the other side
of the square
but didn't mention any of the ones they
just mentioned
so there's something it's been commented
by one philosopher that it's almost like
there's an ontological landslide things
come
in and out of existence for the left
hemisphere
and when it was pointed out to these
people what they'd missed
they became angry irritable and
frustrated which is a typical
left hemisphere emotional term
impatient to dismiss this um
so i think that's intriguing it's just
one image i mean the very dramatic one
is to do with denying that you have
parts of the body
and as was pointed out by um fritz
langella i think
way back in the second decade of the
20th century
they don't only deny after a right
hemisphere stroke that they have
the left half of the body which is not
functioning because of the right
hemisphere stroke
they will become very irritable if
questions are asked about it or they
will just go blank
i mean they will be talking perfectly
coherently and they're asked about that
they will go
stum or they will become very irritated
and if you force them to recognize that
they have a body on that side although
they're perfectly intelligent people
they know they must always have had a
left half of their body
they will deny and he says it's as
though they never had a left half of the
body
it's not only that it's not there now it
never was for them and never will be
now that's what i mean when i say that
there are different
levels of creativity of the world or the
creation of the world through attention
i should
say um in the two hemispheres
now you're in your new book and and to
some degree in the master and this
emissary
you're also making you're mixing your
neurological analysis with philosophical
speculation and
you're trying to solve a problem so
maybe you could tell us what the problem
is that
and and and then we can discuss the
solution
well i suppose the problem is the one
that i mentioned
that there is a puzzle about why uh
brains are set up in this rather odd way
that
but you're also pointing to a kind of
philosophical malaise
right so there's a there's a conceptual
problem but also
an emotional or or broad scale
philosophical problem
and there is there is indeed and indeed
if i may say so the book
that i hope will come out fairly soon
called
the matter with things which is a pun on
several levels because i think it's a
critique not only of the way we think
now but of our obsession with
thinking of the world as composed of
things and that only matter exists
but anyway in that book what i'm really
trying to do is marry
science and philosophy again they they
never should have been separated
science cannot properly be done by
philosophy many
without philosophy many scientists and
philosophers have commented on this over
the years
and the divorce has been disastrous for
them both you get a mindless kind of
science that jumps to very naive
conclusions
that everything is mechanical and you
get a kind of
philosophy that thinks it's above
dirtying its hands with science now i
think
each of these parties can benefit from
a refrosmal which is long overdue
and it's that that i try to do in this
very big book to show how
strands of neurology philosophy and
physics
and even of world mythologies come
together to show the same
very similar pictures the same
gestaltene the same
differences between a world such as the
world brought into being by the
left-handed
and a world such as is brought into
being by the right hemisphere and
perhaps before going on any further you
did invite me earlier to say something
about what those differences are
well to try and sum it up very quickly
what i'd say is for the left hemisphere
things are known familiar
literally things that are unfamiliar are
better dealt with by the right
hemisphere until the left-handers
can go oh i see it's one of those and
put it in a category box
they're more distinct in fact they're
probably entirely fragmented or
isolated in the left hemisphere whereas
there
the right hemisphere sees that nothing
is ever ultimately
um unconnected from everything else
um things in the left hemisphere are
frozen
they don't move they don't change things
in the right hemisphere constantly
flowing and changing although
flowing and changing and remaining the
same are not necessarily
um a an opposition as we know
uh heraclitus my favorite philosopher
said
by changing it remains the same which is
the image of a river which is never ever
still for a moment but the river
outside my house that was there at
breakfast time is probably there now um
so in that sense it's remained and
we're all i believe like these rivers
all living beings are in fact probably
everything that exists is as heraclitus
pointed out
so what other things the left hemisphere
abstracts it tends to abstract from the
body it tends to abstract from
the context and something i
learned very early on in life was the
importance of context how it utterly
changes
anything that somebody says or any image
and this is particularly true of course
of literature which i
um you know studied and taught for for a
certain while when i was a young man
that once you start paraphrasing a poem
and taking its sentiments out of the
context they've utterly changed
themselves and no longer what they were
and the left hemisphere is more
interested in categories the right
hemisphere in the unique case
so it sees that you're not just a member
of a certain group you take certain
boxes you fall into that category
but that you're massively complicatedly
different
and i mean this has a very real basis
you know when you look at
neurological patients people who have
right hemisphere strokes are examples
uh two i know of that both come
from uh the same research group in
switzerland but
uh involve um
a farmer who used to know all his cows
by name
and after the right hemisphere right
parietal
stroke he couldn't really
well he not only couldn't tell his cows
one from another but he could hardly
tell a cow from a horse
and another woman who very plaintively
commented after right hemisphere stroke
she'd spent her whole life studying the
birds of
switzerland she was an authority on them
and she said all the birds look the same
so that's what happens in the left
hemisphere world
quality is replaced by quantity
uniqueness is replaced by the category
and then again the the left hemisphere
um tends to
see things as um
inanimate where the right hemisphere
will see them as animate
well a category a category implies in
some sense that
the the members of that category are
indistinguishable
right because otherwise you don't have a
category you just have particularity and
so
you can imagine that that i mean
to understand this completely you have
to understand to some degree what
categories are for but
or what yeah what categories are for
at least in part you put things that you
can act towards the same way
in the same category and so young
children might
think of cats and dogs as dogs all of
them as dogs because they're
cuddly petable entities
not because they have four legs or
because they have fur but because you
interact with you the same way
then you can differentiate cats and dogs
as you get a little older but the first
category
dog which is petable things is a
perfectly reasonable category
and you can imagine that once a
categorical structure has been imposed
that it's easy just to see the category
i i wrote an
essay in my new book um which is called
beyond order
about the function of artists and i
believe that
part of what artists do and i think this
is maybe you can tell me but i think it
might reflect the differences that
you're talking about
when i was a kid i lived in a small town
and
i can remember all the houses on my
block
i can remember them in detail they're
familiar to me as
individual entities but now that i'm an
adult
i live i've lived on this street for
like 20 years but
the houses are indistinguishable to me i
can't see them
as different entities and i think it's
because i'm so familiar with the
category house
which is a practical category that i
can't see
beyond the category and it's very
efficient because i know what houses do
they sit there you don't have to pay
attention to them
and so it's really a useful perceptual
shorthand just to see the category
and but what an artist will do is take
you outside the category and make you
see that
the particulars again that you're
missing that the
and i i guess that's partly the context
to remind you of what's beyond
what your memory forces you now to see
and is that akin to the to this
distinction that you're making between
the left and the right
well it is a distinction it's a related
distinction but not exactly the same
distinction
i mean interestingly it relates to the
difference
a very important difference in fact i
think probably the single most important
difference of all
which doesn't at first strike people
partly because they're so used to living
in a world of representations
that is the distinction between the
presence of something
as it comes into being for you and your
mental representation of it which is
like a caricature
or a category thing or a verbal sign
so that the left hemispheres
addiction if you like to understanding
things via language
is very important because after all um
language makes everything the same you
know as as nietzsche said it makes the
uncommon common
because you know when you say somebody's
got brown hair or something
then you've got everything just like in
a category but when you see that person
there's something quite different about
the way their hair is and so forth so
and you'd find that out if you painted
it you know because you wouldn't paint
it with brown paint you'd paint it with
a multitude of colors if you were really
looking
you certainly would and you'd see that
it wasn't bro and i mean
artists play with was it manet who
painted the haystacks
in or monet i don't remember in
at multiple different times of the year
and the haystack
i mean the shape was the same but the
haystack was completely different and
that's
really in some sense what he was
portraying was
the category is haystack but the reality
is
is extraordinarily complex and
but well this is the category the
category
seems to have functional significance so
you dump things together
that you can act towards the same way
and then
a word is labeled on top of that to to
to
to serve as an even further compressed
shorthand for that category
so you have a complex world that's
that's yes it's multitudinous
and and too complex to even see and then
there's a perceptual act that
categorizes that into like a perceptual
image
house say and then there's a further
compression and eradication of
information that enables that to be
represented by a word
um and now well the greek philologist
max mueller
said it's interesting that we read
encyclopedias we have dictionaries
we read books and we are with all the
his words but none of the things
that these words represents actually
exists
because in the act of being represented
they are no longer the thing
that was present the very fact of
representing it suddenly stops the
presence of the thing
for me this is very vivid in wordsworth
and this comes back to some of the
things you were saying about the
liveliness of the childhood mind
that when he was a young man
and 50 years a boy rambling in the lake
district
the world was very much still alive to
him and coming into being for him
but that as a man he can't went back
there and as it were
couldn't avoid seeing the landscape as
oh
a picturesque mountain a picturesque
lake
one of those if you like and this is
what he means by
the phrase the shades of the prison
house growing around the growing
closing round the growing boy in his
intimations
uh of of um immortality on refugees yes
so early childhood
so um this is from
this book there was a time when meadow
grove and stream
the earth and every common sight to me
did seem
appareled in celestial light the glory
and the
glory and the freshness of a dream yes
that's it
this is what i'm referring to and this
really is one of the more important
differences i would say probably the
core difference
that as it were one world is real
vibrant unknown in part
only known ever to a degree and ever
more coming into being an ever more
coming into knowledge for the right
hemisphere
and for the left hemisphere already cold
finished known
dead put in a book stuffed on the shelf
filed away
and we now live so much in this virtual
represented world partly because we're
very much cut off from nature
which constantly reminds you of its
vivid uncertain liveliness
it confronts you with its audacious
beauty and vitality all the time partly
because we've
learned to cut our minds off from our
bodies and so we think in this
enormously abstract way
and partly because of city life partly
because of
technology which means we interact with
two-dimensional screens
rather than the three-dimensional depth
which is in a room when you're with
someone which is why as you know
and i know because we both help patients
in our time
that it's very important to be in the
room with the patient it's a completely
different thing that happens
from anything you can do on the
telephone or even like this
so part of the the philosophical case
that you're making
is i believe that while we're
we we have a terrible conundrum as human
beings
we we need in some sense for the
purposes of efficiency to move towards
the most efficient representations
possible
and this has real bearing on the nature
of perception itself so i know for
example that even in the primary visual
cortex so
in principle you know this but i'm going
to explain it for people who are
listening
as as the signals as the pattern signals
from your retina move back towards your
brain they move upwards
so to speak through a hierarchy of
processing units
and even at the first stages of that
processing
there's still more top down input from
other brain
centers than there is input from the
retinal structures themselves
and so what that implies is that even at
the beginnings of perception
you know if you think about it as being
built up from perceptual elements up
towards the whole gestalt which isn't
exactly accurate but it'll do for now
even at the beginnings of the visual
process there's more input from what's
inside than there is from the external
world so to speak or at least as much
and then what seems to happen as we age
is that perhaps
is that increasingly that
perception becomes solipsistic and so
we're only seeing what we know and
that's externally efficient because
it's very hard to build up a new
perception you have to really
investigate something in detail to see
it anew
whereas if it's the same old thing that
you've seen 10 000 times you can already
use what you know
and it's not surprising you'd be annoyed
if you were forced to jump out of that
because there's a tremendous amount of
work that has to be done if you want to
see something for the first time again
well as we both know people would rather
deny
obvious truths than let go of
a cherished belief so um that that's
certainly right and we don't
perceive the world as um
you know in a naive way we come to the
world
with with our history with our vast
range of experience and so as you say
there's top down
effects on on the lower end of things of
the lower end of perception
from higher cognitive functions but
that's an image of something very
important to
the philosophy i try to put across in
the matter with things
which is that in order to understand any
element
in experience it's at least as important
to see what holes it goes to make up
or potentially can go to make up as it
is to see what
it turns into when you break it down in
fact often it's not very revealing to
find out what happens when you break it
down
and so in a way every suffers from that
it's like psychology is a discipline
that consists at least in its present
form mostly of
disparate experiments which demonstrate
very particular things about people
about how people behave in very
particular circumstances
but there's nothing there's very little
that unites that
back up to something that's that's
that isn't merely fragmentary
observation and so it's very difficult
to get a grip out
on and there's billions of potential
separate observations
and and they're not that helpful in some
sense
well it's all part of the world picture
which from the philosophical point of
view is the purpose
of the long book which i sent
you in manuscript the the matter with
things
effectively i can state quite simply
that i i want to give a considered
um response
to the philosophy of our age which is
that there is only matter
and that things are understood by
reducing them to their parts and this
doesn't change them
it's a very naive philosophy
it's simplistic and it's immoral because
it changes the way we
treat the world and other people and
nature
it changes our idea of who we are in a
very damaging way
ruling out things that other traditions
have
traditionally held as very powerful and
you know coming back to your comment
about
how people cling on to things that they
believe and
it's much more difficult to try and see
something in a different way
especially with age this is why of
course most
traditions of spiritual growth um
enjoin on the person paradoxes to see
things
in a completely new way that violates
all the ways that they thought they knew
so i use paradox in this new book but
not in some blind way in fact i showed
that what
we mean by a paradox is that the view of
the left hemisphere of something and the
view taken of the right hemisphere of
the same thing
can never actually completely marry up
they they have different qualities and
if you push
the comparison or the the desire to make
them logically come together
too far you end up with a paradox and
this started happening
you know early on in the greek uh
the ancient greek period of philosophy
with zeno
this is where the first paradoxes come
from and i have a whole chapter on
paradox
which i see as generated by the desire
of the left hemispheres to say it must
be this or it must be that
clinging on preferentially to the very
fragmentary view of the left hemisphere
see the left hemisphere is not good at
understanding
that sounds a very blanket statement and
it is
but the whole of the first part of that
book the the new book
is massively more
thorough um neuropsychology than is in
the master in his emissary so it's a
it's
it's about as thorough as i could
possibly make it
and what i do is i look at the ways in
which we have any
chance of getting an idea of what the
world is what are the portals of entry
of if you like information about the
world to us
and i take it that they they it depends
very much on
our attention how we dispose our
attention perception
the judgments we form on the basis of
perception
um the ways in which we uh
apprehend what we're dealing with rather
than comprehend it in other words grasp
it
as we say with the right hand of the
left hemisphere
take it use it um
how we understand it in terms of
emotional intelligence
which is not a small thing it's the
whole way in which we understand
everything human by emotional i don't
mean sort of
um in some you know what i mean i i'm
talking about social and emotional
understanding the sort of thing that
is absent in people with autism um and
cognitive intelligence this may surprise
people but that
all these things and creativity so
creativity
intelligence of the cognitive kind iq
kind
emotional and social intelligence
apprehension
is a separate case i'll come to that in
a second
perception and attention and judgment
all these
are better performed by the right hand
is the only apprehension
is better performed by the left
hemisphere so the only thing the left
hemisphere is better at
is getting a hold on either an idea
very precise clear one or on
a a thing that it wants to use but all
the manifold complexity which our
intelligence brings to bear in order to
understand the world all of that
is better done by the right hemisphere
and i can say that
on the basis not just of experiments in
normal subjects
but on seeing what happens when you have
either left hemisphere damage or right
hemisphere damage
to to summarize a vast chunk of
information which i hope will be
you know there for people to read very
very soon um
to summarize that very briefly what one
would say is that when you have damage
to the right hemisphere
your grasp of reality is the main thing
that's impaired
you don't understand it you don't
connect with it your
ability to understand what's going on
disappears
whereas when you have a right hemisphere
sorry when you have a
that's when you have a right hemisphere
when you have a left hemisphere stroke
the main things are you have difficulty
speaking and using your right hand
they're practically very important
but the essentially the understanding of
the world the grasp of the
meaning of the world so as you see
towards gratification but
the overall comprehension of the world
is sustained by the right hemisphere
okay so let me ask you a question can i
sure go ahead right okay
and then all right okay let me just
make this point because i want to you
people might say well
okay but so what we've both got right
and left hemispheres
so we're not missing anything so does it
matter well yes it matters very
importantly for my philosophical project
because as i show in the second part of
the book where i
look at the proper contributions to
understanding made by reason
science intuition and imagination
what i can show is that in
those attempts to grasp we are we can
see the world
we can see the signature of the right
hemisphere or the signature of the left
hemisphere on a particular model
so if we have two possible models of a
certain action or
an aspect of reality or of space or time
which i deal with in the third part of
the book
and indeed in philosophical history and
in the history of physics and so on
there have
tended to be opposing views of the world
once you know how the left hemisphere
sees it and how the right hemisphere
tends to see things
you can see the hallmark of the left
hemisphere's understanding on a certain
philosophical standpoint
on a certain scientific take of the
world
and you can see the hallmark and the
the imprint of the right hemisphere in
certain other ways of reasoning
and of science and philosophy so this is
very important
because up till now we've never been
able to judge between these two we've
got a
we've got b we just have to go can't
tell we can't reconcile them we can't do
without either of them
that's true we ultimately that's true
but we can get a very sharp idea
i believe now of which of these is
fallacious which one is going to lead us
down a blind alley which one is
out of touch with reality and which one
is more in touch with reality
i just wanted to say that because it's
behind the whole philosophical drift of
my book which is
how do we know who we are i asked
platinus this question
who are we that's effectively the
question
what is the cosmos what is nature and
how do we all relate
sorry hand over to you no no that that's
good
um okay so
to do something you have to zero in on
it so
let me lay something out for you and and
then i'm gonna ask you a specific
question about it so imagine that i'm
i'm concentrating on the computer screen
i'm attending to it i'm writing a book
okay so the question might be well what
am i doing while i'm writing that book
what is it to write that book
well in in at the at the most
focused level of my consciousness the
most focal level
that involves voluntary control of my
fingers
i'm going to be typing single letters
and there are muscle movements that are
associated with that but i don't really
know what the muscle movements are i
know how to move my fingers that's the
highest level of resolution i can manage
i can press
t with my left hand and h with my right
hand and and
with each with these two fingers and so
that's sort of where the pedal hits the
metal in some sense that's where my
intent meets the world
okay so but i'm not typing letters sorry
i am typing letters but at the same time
i'm typing words
and at the same time i'm typing words
i'm typing phrases
and then i'm typing sentences and i'm
typing paragraphs
and i'm typing chapters and then i'm
typing books
and then the book itself is an artifact
that's nested
inside higher order structures so
while i'm i'm writing the book but the
reason i can write the book is because
i'm
i'm imagining a world within which the
book is nested
and so i'm focusing on something very
specific like i can't write the book
without
pushing the letter t with my left index
finger
but i also can't write the book without
apprehending the book as a whole
and you know when i edit i edit not
letters because i can spell
but i edit words i substitute one word
for another i edit phrases i edit
sentences i edit at the paragraph level
like all of these levels actually exist
now
is it reasonable to suppose so
sorry i'm going to add one more level
outside that so you might ask well why
am i writing a book and it might be well
because
i'm a practicing scientist and and why
is that
uh uh important it's well i'm uh i'm a
dutiful citizen let's say trying to
uphold my moral responsibility
and you might say well why is that
important i would say well that's part
of
my my proper moral engagement with the
world
and then i can't go farther outside than
that now
is it reasonable to suppose if you think
about that whole structure as a kind of
lens that focuses us in the world is it
reasonable to suppose that it's the left
hemisphere
so to speak that's concentrating on the
t's and the h's
and that as you move up that hierarchy
to broader and broader levels of
conceptualization that that
that the manner in which those higher
levels are conceptualized shifts more
and more to the right or is processed
more and more by the right is that a
reasonable way of looking at it
i think you could but i i'd need to sort
of gloss it a bit um
and what you've beautifully described is
what the right hemisphere knows and
which john summarized by saying if you
try to
get hold of any one thing and pull it
you find that they bring with it the
whole of the rest of the universe
yet that sentence you're writing is
is uh informed by your personal history
and the history therefore of your
culture and therefore and so on and so
on and so forth
so everything that has gone to make you
is present in
that business of the book um and so
you're not of course at any one time
aware of more than a tiny bit
but there's a very f uh fallacious and
uh superficial uh argument that if
you're not conscious of it
in that sense of the word conscious then
somehow you're not doing it
but of course you are the whole thing
emanates from what i call the field of
view
now suppose rather than you know we can
take the example of the typing
but you wouldn't be able to type at all
if you were thinking about what your
fingers were doing
um and you know but nonetheless
it would be stupid to say that you're
unconscious while you're typing of
course you're not unconscious
somebody playing a bach fugue has got to
use all their fingers and their hands
you know and their feet at the same time
and if they concentrated they could only
concentrate and focus on one finger of
course that would stop the whole music
for a start
but they're they're conscious of course
they're just as conscious when
the whole thing's happening as they are
if they think about the finger and stop
it
so what this illustrates is what alfred
north whitehead
was keen to point out that as soon as we
master something we relegate it to
another part of the mind that we don't
any longer have to focus on
and the focusing of of tension is costly
he said
it's like um cavalry charges in battle
it should only be done rarely uh
you need fresh horses and it comes at a
high cost so
that's a good analogy because you build
up you build a little machine that the
things
the things the things that the things
that we do
unconsciously are in no way inferior
stuff
so for example the bar fugue is not
inferior when a surgeon
is learning he or she has to be very
conscious of what
he or she is doing the actual business
of the hand cutting
but when the surgeon is very skilled
he can hum listen to the radio chat with
colleagues and it's all happening
similarly a chess player a bad chess
player has to be conscious
of every move but a really good one it's
not unconscious it's very very highly
conscious but it's not
focused now my distinction to sorry
finally answer your question is that is
that
focused tension this focal attention
detail is what the left hemisphere does
it can only
take in about three degrees for the
attentional arc so it's incredibly
limited
and as as whitehead says it has its uses
in an emergency but really it's not a
satisfactory way
for living and what i think is happening
is that we are now
more and more saying anything that i'm
not actually focusing on right now
doesn't exist
all the implicit stuff all the
unconscious stuff
all the things that go to make up the
richness
of our both cognitive and emotional and
embodied cells
isn't really important we focus down on
this tiny bit that the
relatively unintelligent left hemisphere
knows about and is aware of so when i
say
conscious and unconscious i like to say
don't think of these as two separate
realms like you know two tanks
with perhaps a trap and things can pop
up from the lower tank into the higher
tank or whatever
but instead think of it like a stage and
there's a spotlight
and the spotlight may just illuminate
one part of the stage but the rest of
the stage hasn't gone
anywhere it's still there and you just
need to move the spotlight and suddenly
it's there again in the in the middle of
what you're thinking about
that's how our that's how i would see
that question
okay so so let's go back to this typing
example again
just so when you learn to type
you're going to be paying conscious
attention to pushing the t's and the h's
as you learn to type you start perhaps
being conscious more of
maybe you're attending at the level of
the phrase like
you don't have to be consciously
attentive to those things you've built
automated machinery for
now they say when kids learn to read it
isn't enjoyable to begin with because
it's effortful to learn to process the
letters
and it's effortful to learn to process
the words and it's not until
they can automatize the letter and word
processing and so they can read the word
at a glance
that they start to be able to be
conscious of the phrase and the sentence
and that's when they get the meaning
from the text and that's when it starts
to become
enjoyable right it's not just effortful
and then
so the consciousness of a reader isn't
consciousness of letters and it's not
consciousness of words it's
consciousness of something
like the interplay between sentences and
paragraphs and it's like your
consciousness floats
above the highest level of
automatization that you've been able to
manage
is it does that seem reasonable to you
well
i mean when you're playing a musical
piece for example you don't pay
attention to what you've practiced
because you've got that
you pay attention to the sequencing of
what you've practiced and
the the greater a musician you are the
higher up in the abstraction hierarchy
you can focus because you've
you've automated all the lower stuff
well
and that comes back to to what i'm sorry
no i was i was i'm trying to get the
relationship between that and the
hemispheric specialization
well i i i think i've done my best to
point out that the the right hemisphere
is the one that is able to attend to the
whole gestalt
ultimately is dealing not in fragmentary
entities that have to be put together
but in gestaltene that already exists
and unnested so that you go down from
one level and you find another
you know famously you can go from the
from the body to the organ to the tissue
to the cell to the organelle to the you
know
and each of these at each stage
um is a whole that has its own qualities
and its own rules really and
works in a semi-autonomous way so
there's always freedom
between the levels of understanding
there's always space
it's rather like the gaps in the
structure of where the light gets in you
know if you tighten everything up then
you've got total darkness
so what we're trying to do all the time
is to know
enough to be able to act but to leave it
open so that we can know more
and really understand where we are and
what we're doing when we're acting
so i think these are significant
differences between the left-handers
which is utterly goal directed
um and very direct in that in the way in
which it
achieves or aims to achieve its goal and
the right hemisphere which is
sustaining this and also seeing the goal
in
a wider whole you know the the reason of
typing these letters is not just to make
the keys go up and down and to have a
bit of paper at the end of it
but because you want to influence minds
that are now
unaware of this but we'll know about it
soon so
i think it's the difference between this
very again whitehead says as a
civilization advances by the number of
uh actions that can be made
automatically or below the level
sorry without thinking without thinking
because thinking thinking is thinking is
a very complex thing isn't it i mean
what is it
and a number of people have commented
rather along the lines that i'm saying
that it's not so much right to say i
think as in cogito
but uh in the words of liestenberg the
18th century german
philosopher and physicist um esdenkt
estanktinmir something is thinking
in me and that is the me
it's not separate and it's not
unconscious in the sense of
it's it's it has no life it has no
meaning it has no purpose it has no
direction absolutely not it has all
those things
and one of the things i'm trying to
argue in the last part of
may i say something just about the
structure of this book i started off on
it this new book i'm just going to say a
little bit more about it yeah
yeah so yeah well we're trying to grasp
something large
going through its parts so it's not such
a simple thing to do
it's not a simple thing to do so the
first part of the book i've explained
it gives one an insight into a simple
fact that in terms of having access to
the
reality of the world the right
hemisphere is better than the left
and it has a special take if you like
which we can recognize so that when
we're having to choose
between two opposites we can choose one
if we want to over the other
in the second part of the book i'm
looking at the pathways to knowledge
using attention perception judgment
intelligence on how do we put them to
use
well i think the main ones are science
reason i think most people would say
they're important i would say
intuition and imagination are also
vastly important
now none of these is infallible none of
these
can say that it can deal with everything
there are proper limits to science
otherwise you're
peddling untenable naive scientism
uh but it is a very important thing for
us
to respect and to do honorably and
reason
is enormously important i use science
and reason as the basis of my book
but again reason as pascal famous
mathematician
and philosopher said reason is poor if
it cannot see
its own limitations and
so it has limitations but it can achieve
a very great deal
and the same actually is true of
intuition it's had a very bad press in
recent years because
i think again psychologists i think
you've
alluded to this they like things that
can be taken down into bits and shown
them
we can find the mechanisms intuition is
a bit hard for that
and imagination has been again
relegated to the sort of children's play
box that this is something
um to do with fantasy whereas in fact i
argue that quite the opposite that
whereas fantasy may be an interesting
decoration on things that we already
know
and the left hemisphere can do that
imagination is
actually how we go to meet the world and
understand it and we have to imagine it
into being there is no alternative
if we are not imaginatively engaged with
the world we just can't see a lot of
things that are there
so
together not just one or two as we now
do sorry carry on
well i i wanted to comment on your your
your discussion of imagination and and
the manner in which it brings the world
into being
so we've already discussed the
fact that the realm of your experience
is dependent to some degree on your
attention and that that's associated
with intent
and intent seems to me to be it's future
oriented
to have an intent intent means to
attempt to move from one place to
another and hypothetically it's a better
place because
why move otherwise and so to act in the
world
with intent means that you're playing
out something that's
imaginative because to posit that one
thing is better than another
and and therefore want to move towards
it you have to have imagined up a better
world and so what that means in some
sense is that we're always meeting the
world in a way
that imposes our imaginative attempts to
make it better
upon us upon the world but that also
brings the world into being
and so so
and i guess i'm i'm saying that because
i'm trying to grapple with the why of
your book again
you're you're implying throughout and
more than implying
that that we we have a paucity of
viewpoint that's
demotivating and dangerous and you're
implying as well that that has something
to do with
our obsessive concentration or
utilization of left hemisphere functions
that that reminds me of heidegger to
some degree in his claim that
moderners use the world as produce you
know that we tend to
reduce everything to its functional
utility
insofar as it can be exploited like i
have some sympathy for that because we
have to exploit the world to live but
yes it it it it
so let's say we do lose something by
being specific
we and narrow we gain something which is
functional utility
what do we do about that you're trying
to understand it and why it is what do
we do to fight against it
well um that's a whole separate question
but at the moment i'm trying to unpack
what the problem is and
okay well i won't push it i think
congratulations
i mean i mean quite what we do about it
is
the million dollar question and we may
not be in a position
unless we radically alter the way in
which we think about the world
understand it and feel it and experience
it and interact with it we may not have
a world
in which to live so it's a pretty
important
topic but um so having sort of more or
less
as it were gone over what are the
portals to understanding what are the
paths to understanding
and then in the part three which is
really if you like
the reason we've had parts one and two
you can't get to part three without them
but
when you get there we want to know so
what is the world like
and so i look at the structure
of the world the theories about it and
what we can tell from physics and from
the hemisphere hypothesis what parts of
it we may be perceiving
with the left hemisphere and what we may
be seeing with the right
and i look at the structure in sense of
the coming together of opposites
and the very interesting philosophical
question of the relationship between the
one and the many
and then in the rest of the book i look
at
time space motion
meaning largely flow but all kinds of
motion
matter and consciousness
uh value
purpose and the sense of the sacred now
i
argue that these
elements like consciousness are not
secondary they're not derivative
it's actually irrational to suppose they
are
reason is on the side of the fact that
they are ontological primaries
and i argue that actually also unpack
that for people because it's
there's a lot but it would take it's
very interesting
well i can unpack the phrase what i mean
by ontological primary is that it can't
be reduced
to um other terms it can't be said that
as long as you look at um a brain in a
certain way you can work out what
consciousness is
consciousness is sue generous it is of
its own kind
it is not something that is derived from
anything
it has to be a primary constituent of
the universe this is not a particularly
um any longer controversial view
um it's held by many philosophers now
in the form of pan psychism in which
something like consciousness is in the
cosmos and the cosmos
perhaps exists inside consciousness not
my consciousness but
a consciousness field um
and there are plenty of neuroscientists
who who say this too
um colin blake more um
not known for for being kind of away
with the fairies but they say this too
um but i would also argue and it's a
perhaps um harder thing to make
comprehensible in a very short space
but then actually values are things that
are there
they're not things we make up they're
not things that um
are like i rather like that
they are they are built into the drive
of everything and i think that the
cosmos has drives you can describe them
in all sorts of ways it has
the fact that it changes and moves in
certain ways according to
quote laws which may actually not be
laws but maybe temporary habits we don't
know they may be evolving too
but the very fact that this thing has
this energy to evolve
to differentiate to produce
differentiation within union
this is a value of a kind you can't get
behind these and most of our
values other than those of utility this
is good
for me and i want to have more of it
which is what the left hemisphere is
devoted to
most of those other values are not
reducible to
sheer in a material greed or
or you know feathering your own nest
they're often actually
the things that are vastly important
probably the whole
point of the being consciousness at all
is to come to appreciate
the meaning of truth goodness and beauty
to have a sense of something or
inspiring which is really what we mean
when we talk about the sacred
that we're humble enough to say we don't
know everything we probably
will never know i mean why should we
that's also a totally irrational idea
that our brains are so constructed that
we should know everything
i mean i might mouse might think that if
it could think that much you would think
it knows everything but it doesn't you
know
um so and we're evolving there may be
creatures in the future who think what
the hell did
homo sapiens in 2021 know you know so
i just want to get back into the frame
that not
all the things that matter to us they
are enormously important
aspects of the of a universe that is not
dead
and static unless given a push
not without purpose not without meaning
not without value
these things are in the grain in the
warp and the weft of the cosmos
of that i'm certain and the job is for
us
to find this and most philosophers
um wise people sages whatever you like
to call them
in the past have adopted a view of
the cosmos which is exactly the one that
one would expect the right hemisphere to
hold
which is one which things are not always
certain or known they're changing
they're interconnected
but the whole thing has a meaning it is
not a
heap of fragments that don't mean
anything um
the modern malays so that's really where
i'm driving at if you see that
that's that's the that's the
philosophical goal is to help people see
something that i think they already
intuit
i mean that was a response to the the
master in his m3
um apart from people enormously movingly
writing to me saying things i never
thought i would ever hear
from writing a book like your book
changed my life and i'm sure you've had
this too
but you know people saying what you're
saying i kind of knew
i've known this but i couldn't find any
way of articulating it
well there's a reason why you couldn't
find a way of articulating it and that
is
articulation in language is controlled
by the left hemisphere it developed
very good tools for mapping out the
world in a way that is very useful to
its purposes
but the the important things are hard to
articulate in words they're implicit
meanings
all the deep things like love religion
poetry music how do you say these in
words how do you say them in language
but they have extraordinary meaning and
power they're the things we live
for not for the things that we can say
put down in a notebook if you know what
i mean
so what's what's driven you in this
direction
do you think i mean you made a very
large number of claims in that last
section of thought um yeah for example
you you've come to the belief that
value is somehow implicit in the
structure of being
that's what i understood what you said
and correct me if i'm wrong
that's right okay that it's unfolding
across time and i mean i've been
thinking about this
this that exact issue an awful lot um
do you it's very difficult to formulate
this question
so imagine that imagine that we're drawn
towards an ideal
human beings are drawn towards an ideal
and imagine that you can
you can you can detect that draw
by your own dissatisfaction in part is
that you don't feel you're living
properly or your conscience is bothering
you you feel that there's something more
to be attained
you're embarrassed at your
insufficiencies right so there's this
ideal that's
pulling you onward and judging you at
the same time
and that ideal might be well the ideal
human being that's one way of thinking
about it and
that's partly why i got so interested in
hero mythology i mean
do you is it re is it a reasonable
conclusion of your line of thinking that
the notion of the ideal human being is
somehow built into
the structure of the cosmos because the
classic
i don't i don't know how to no it it's
it's not no i don't think that at all
i want to scotch that immediately okay
well
how do you scotch that if you start with
your presuppositions like
well because i don't my presuppositions
have nothing to do with an already
conceived plan that is
just being acted out this is not what i
wasn't implying
it wasn't necessarily all right well
okay but let all right okay well i'm
glad you weren't
but a lot of people think that if i say
these things i must be positing an
engineering god
who sort of tinkers with things and
makes things happen according to his
purpose yeah okay that's fair i mean i
was implying i was implying that in some
sense i mean
the question would be where does your
where does your insistence that
values are part of the structure of
being like
where does that find its limit because
the classic limit of that is something
like
is in fact the definition of the utmost
place of value in some sense
is almost indistinguishable from the
claim that there is a god
and so a god is not the same as an
engineering god and i
i take enormous pains in the book it
costs me more than anything i've ever
written
to write the chapter called the sense of
the sacred in which i try
to help people to a place where
they can understand why people use this
extraordinarily difficult word god
you know it's not a satisfactory term
but it's the term we have to have to
name
an aspect of our experience that if we
don't name it
disappears from our lives and that's not
to say
that there isn't something there that is
that merits whatever we mean when we say
divine
i mean we we haven't defined we haven't
defined what we mean by divine
and we're back in the nets of language
we're trapped in the nets of language
as shelling said but what i'm suggesting
is that as whitehead suggested and come
on whitehead
was also the co-author with russell of
the principia
mathematica he wasn't um a fantasist
he had this i think incredibly deep idea
that whatever one likes to call the
divinity
god whatever is the thing
that the cosmos has relation with
relation is at the core of being i even
argued that relation
is prior to the relata prior to the
things that are related
that sounds nonsense how can you relate
how can you have a relation if there
isn't anything yet to relate
but there's a wonderful image called um
in indian mythology called indra's net
which covers the universe and in it the
idea is that the filaments of the net
exist
before the net before the crossing
points which are the things we see
and on those crossing points there are
little gems which reflect every other
gem in the net
and that's a that would take a very long
time to unpack but perhaps it can set
things going in people's minds
but the idea i gesture to the right
hemisphere
is that relation is prior to anything at
all
really and that therefore the the
whatever you mean by god and whatever we
mean by
the cosmos are in some sort of dynamic
relation which is an evolving one
in which the outcome is excitingly not
known
if it were known it would all be some
horrible possibly sadistic
um play uh by an all
mighty all-knowing god i mean then look
i'm going to be talking to rowan
williams shortly but
i don't want to go go into all that i
mean by that
i don't think god is omniscient and
omnipotent omnipotent but i don't think
he's not either
just in the same way i don't think he's
green and i don't think he's not green
i think the terms are wrong uh but you
know we can go there if we want them
later or another day but the thing what
i'm what i'm
saying is that these that god is
discovering becoming unfulfilling
whatever god is through the relationship
which classically in most religions is
described as love
which is after all just a like a form of
gravity
in the world of of life and emotion
rather than just in the world of
of of um the so-called inanimate um
so that therefore
we are coming into being god is coming
into being
and we're necessary to one another's
coming into being it's not that god does
a bit to us and then we do a bit back to
god
it's like i've read a very good book i
keep mentioning it by a young
microbiologist in america called
kritishama called interdependence
and she argues very importantly that
it's not just that
um certainly it's not just that an
animal or an organism molds its
environment
nor is it just good enough to recognize
that while an animal
affects and shapes its environment the
environment
shapes the the animal or the organism
but that
this is not a you know uh turn-by-turn
process it's not that the animal shapes
the environment should then
uh in its turn shapes the the animal
it's an entirely
simultaneous process of coming into
being of co-creation if you like
now this idea of simultaneous coming
into being is an ancient one
but i think it's a very deep one
philosophically and a very important one
so that accounts for your objection to
the idea of the omniscient determining
god ab absolutely
absolutely because the the god has
god would have no creation creation is
not really just the unfolding of
something that's already there
creation the name of the book what's the
name of the book by the microbiologist
it's just called interdependence it's by
kriti sharma
can you spell her last name s-h-a-r-m-a
it's quite a short read okay i'm i'm
mentioning her quite a lot these days
okay so let me let me ask you a question
so to get
now i'm gonna try to pack up
what you're doing and so again tell me
if i'm wrong so
we have these opposed viewpoints of the
world
paradoxical viewpoints they're expressed
they make the hemispheric differences
necessary or they're a consequence of
the hemispheric differences
if there wasn't a paradox we wouldn't
need the two hemispheres we need these
two different ways of looking at things
we've tilted we're in danger of tilting
too far to
a left hemisphere view and that's
keeping us from
from what it's keeping us from
apprehension of the
relationship with the sacred that you're
describing
the co-creation relationship
is that is that reasonable well it's
ruling out
so much i mean i can't begin to tell you
but you can imagine
all the things that this very reduced
abstract schematic
bureaucratic essentially it's a
bureaucratic
um you know you push something
it has an action on something else and
you know we can predict the outcome we
can organize it that's the left
hemisphere's vision of the world
inanimate stuff that it can move about
very much the industrial revolution was
a kind of
acting out in the outer world of the
world picture of the left hemisphere
in some ways i talk about that more in
the master in his emissary but
um but it's phenomenal it's ruling out
it's ruling out everything really it's
ruling out our ability to understand
to see to see at all i mean a number of
very important people
one of them goethe said you know
thinking is good
but seeing is so much better and i think
we just don't see
things anymore because we don't expect
them we don't understand them we've
ruled them out
from the word go because our world
picture just doesn't contain them
and if you stop doing that and start
attending in a more flexible way
you find there's a massively complex and
fascinating
rich nourishing response to your
attention
it's the absence of that that causes the
meaning crisis which is constantly being
banded about
christ you know the egyptians knew that
the ancient egyptians knew that
yeah because they they they um
they're the god horus is the eye
and its attention and it is horus that
revitalizes osiris and he's the god of
structure
and they saw the the the proper
sovereignty
was a combination of attention and
structure a dynamic combination of
attention and structure
well this is absolutely brilliant
well i quite agree but this is where we
come to
i need to make a correct a possible
misapprehension
there is absolutely nothing wrong with
the view of the right hemisphere it's in
fact
necessary it's part of a of a dialectic
backwards and forwards between these two
ways in which things can be built
you can't have the one in a way without
the other you're quite right we need
them both
but but we live in an age which is
completely obsessed
with the idea of equality as some
eternal
sort of truth about the cosmos i i have
i can see no evidence for this idea it's
a lovely idea a humanly invented idea
which is which is a good one
in society although it can't be realized
and it may actually not be
necessary or even good for it to be
ultimately realized it might lead to
a horrible kind of totalitarianism as
many
20th century philosophers pointed out
but but
the problem with elevating one virtue
above all else
well ideologically well no the point is
this
we need the left and the right but we
need the right to be in control
now this is very important this is the
image of the master and his emissary
the embassy and the master are not equal
the master needs the industry and knows
he needs the emissary the emissary being
inferior doesn't know
that he needs the master so the emissary
is
good as long as he's under the control
of the master
now that image is extraordinarily
important for understanding
this picture of the cosmos and he's
actually
present in ancient chinese
navajo not navajo iroquois
mythologies and so on this idea of the
being an unequal
pair that one has to be the guardian of
the other
and as long as the the one that is as it
were a potential problem remains under
the supervision
of the wise and one that sees all
everything works well for everybody
and that's why in the master in his
emissary i suggest there were three
periods in the west
in early greek civilization in the peak
of roman civilization again at the
renaissance in the west where these were
working well together
but in every case it slid further to the
to the viewpoint of the left hemisphere
and in every case
the civilization has crumbled and i see
the evidence for that all around me
now so i'm not saying that we we just
need these two things
i'm saying we definitely need them both
neither of them is bad
but what is bad is for the
the inferior one the one that sees less
to take control
and it's very easy for it to take
control because like the less
intelligent person that thinks it knows
everything
it thinks i've got it i've understood it
there's no more you know we do
three more experiments and we've cracked
the universe you know it's all just a
matter of
you know a few more years of science and
we'll understand it
i believe that's the case let me
let you in on some of the things i've
been grappling with here so i talked
i talked to matt ridley and bjorn
lawberg recently
and their um enthusiastic
enlightenment rationalists i would say
they're they look at what's happened as
a consequence of the industrial
revolution and the tremendous
technological advances that that's
produced and the
immense increase in human well-being and
they say
we can continue with that into the
future we can produce a world and
perhaps are already producing a world
where poverty is increasingly going to
be a thing of the past and
we can bring the rest of the world up to
the standards of living that
characterize the west and
and we can continue to expand the pie
and i'm not
interested in discussing whether that's
possible or not because
it's possibly possible and possibly not
but it's a particular vision right it's
a vision of
the extension of material comfort to
everyone
and that comfort has been extended
tremendously over the last two or three
hundred years it's it's absolutely
amazing and
i would say in large part it's a
consequence of that left hemisphere
reduction of the world to manageable
bits and the manipulation of it
and and this is not to say anything
negative about your thesis whatsoever
but one of the things i've noticed is
that that materialistic utopian vision
and i'm also not insulting ridley or
lomberg who i admire greatly
that materialistic vision of incremental
material progress
has very little motive power like it
isn't an exciting
story for some reason i and
you know what do we want incremental
improvement when do we want it
in due time it it it's not a gripping
story it's lacking something and
you you're you seem to be pushing
towards
something that might be the medic
medication for that
lack there's there's nothing in that
vision
that speaks of like a grand destiny for
the individual
for society and there are many religious
traditions that insist
that human beings exist in a
relationship with the divine and that
it's only in
in living out that relationship that
life is imbued with the proper kind of
meaning
and proper means sufficient to keep you
from malevolence i suppose
sufficient to be in love with life now
you posited
in some of your statements a while back
that when we're in this co-creation
relationship with the divine
and that isn't too far off from my
understanding of many classical
religious
propositions that human beings
participate in the act of creation
whether we participate in the act of
creating god is a whole different
question but
we can leave that aside i mean you're
so then the question is what's the
question that arises out of that
i'm still i'm still trying to drive down
at exactly what the main point you're
making you've worked on this book for a
tremendous amount of time
something's driving you hard and it's
the revelation of a solution to
to a very important problem and the
revelation seems to be something like
an attempt to explicate a higher order
vision for
to explicate a higher order vision
something that we can aspire to
and the the drive to this
is that i don't think that we live in
an enlightened era we live in
what david bohm called an undarkened era
in which what we think is enlightening
us is in fact
inducing misery the strange thing is
that unarguably when people are
enormously
um poverty-stricken and of course one
needs then
to define what poverty is are people who
lead
um the lives that their ancestors have
lived
as hunter-gatherers are they poor or do
they only become
poor when their whole world is ripped
apart and they're brought into the
nearest large industrial slum
and have no bearings on their life no
relationship with the world no pride and
their health suffers and they kill
themselves
so what is poverty that is a very
important question first
but also remedying poverty extreme
poverty is of course
enormously important no feeling person
could could argue against that
but it's not enough you know as um yes
one rather well known uh one rather
well-known historical figure
said a man cannot live by bread alone
and the thing is that there's only bread
in this story
but that leaves out everything
peter cook he plays the part of a
publisher who says
the trouble with your book is that it
lacks
everything and i feel that these this
kind of philosophy
lacks absolutely everything it's got
nothing whatever to offer now
let me just put that some facts to this
because it may sound
you know it's just my opinion what what
do we know
well fortunately going back to the 30s
school children in america in a certain
system have been asked the same
questions about their happiness
in life at the same age going back now
70 years
and gene twenge who has looked at this
data
which avoids all sorts of problems of
defining what you mean by happy and
uh you know retrospector scopes and all
the rest
you've got the data from the 1930s the
40s the 50s
and nowadays um the numbers of
of children that would um
qualify uh by a very well
authenticated and commonly used standard
as being depressed
is five to eight times what it was in
the 1930s
when poverty was a big issue so
five or eight times not five or eight
percent more
so there's something horrendous we're
doing to ourselves
suicide rates are going up particularly
among women who register much greater
dissatisfaction with life now than they
did 20 years ago interestingly
um because one might think that a number
of things that
would have made life hard for them have
been removed but
it just shows how complicated it is
knowing what works well for people
and three things overall three things
seem to be
incredibly important for human
fulfillment and happiness
and one of them i touched on at the end
of the master in his emissary which is
feeling socially connected
being bound into a meaningful community
of trust that's one the second
is being in the presence of nature just
going off
for half an hour into a forest and being
quiet
has an effect on your blood pressure on
your physical health and so on and these
effects
if practice are greater than those and
going to the gym
and the thing that really struck me is
that in oxford there is the oxford
handbook of religion i think it's called
but it looks at
enormous bodies of evidence about the
well-being
of people who are adherent to a religion
and those who
are not and not only as you very well
might expect
are the people who are not adherent to
religion
much more prone to anxiety depression
drug addiction uh they cope less well
with crisis
uh that they're more vulnerable
generally but
um they're actually physically not so
well
so for example rates of of stroke of
heart disease
are are comparably better amongst the
um the believing group than the
unbelieving group
with the difference between those who do
cardio exercise
you know for several hours a day so and
even smoking it
it is a more powerful effect than
smoking
social connectedness is more powerful
than smoking being in nature i think is
more powerful than
smoking and um being
a part of a religious uh community that
worships is
and even holding um spiritual or
religious views to some extent
is uh a mitigator against um unhappiness
and illness so you know is that any
answer to your question of why
you know why i don't think that matt
ridley's idea of
it's totally left hemisphere idea we
just sort of crank out some more
government
departments do some marvelous technical
things and everybody gets
to be living in a fantasy land of
happiness i don't believe this
well i don't i don't think he i don't
think he believes that i mean he's a
complicated person and
he's more concerned with applying
material resources where they could be
most effectively applied i think the
question of what
what material comfort and plenitude
needs to be embedded in is a different
question i think
it's reasonable to say well we should do
what we can to alleviate
destitution and and and and catastrophic
poverty
we should improve child nutrition we
should eradicate tuberculosis
in to make it available and you've come
to this conclusion was this a shock to
you over the years that you came to the
conclusion that
okay why not i mean the reason i'm
asking is because
it isn't an everyday occurrence in some
sense
for a committed scientist to point out
that
the scientific viewpoint needs to be
embedded inside it
a broader what value-oriented
viewpoint it's something i believe but
it isn't an everyday occurrence for that
to be stated forthrightly and as a
scientist isn't
necessarily the first thing that would
come to mind like have you always
thought this way or
have you come to this as a consequence
of your thinking
well i have the advantage of having come
to science
from a fairly thorough grounding in the
humanities
so i had a philosophy of life that was
based on
reading thinking talking
and i was a relatively aged
customer when i started to study
medicine
uh compared with most most people who do
that
um at least in this country um
so i brought a background which has
always been my passion
an interest in philosophy but not just a
kind of
um forever analytic
philosophy in which you it's more like
more or less like sort of
angels dancing on a pinhead and breaking
everything down to the tiniest parts
this doesn't really particularly
interest me
but a kind of more human philosophy um
which doesn't become theology
but which is open to the idea that there
is more
in the world than we can know or
understand
um but it does sound it sounds like it
is that it has become
theology this isn't a critique like it's
it's an attempt to observe
what what you're telling me it's not a
critique at all it's i'm trying to
understand this
um and and well it depends what you mean
by theology you see
i don't think the most important part of
the relationship with god is necessarily
theology
i i'm not disrespectful of theology but
well when you're claiming that i've read
a lot of i've read a lot of
i've read a lot of for example the
kabbalah
i've acquainted myself with buddhist
philosophy
and i've always been very interested in
taoism
hinduism and the deep wisdom of these
things
including as i say north american native
people
um and even circumpolar people i mean
the the wisdom is embodied in their
mythologies we think of these as
somehow childish myths but in fact these
myths contain and in fact are the only
way of containing or
not containing because they're not ever
contained but of
transmitting um bringing into
into being for other people the things
that are the deep truths and it's that
that motivated me i have only one
you know i'm not going to be alive much
longer
i mean i'm not in in imminent
danger of dying but i mean we're all
actually here for an extraordinary short
time and there was great wisdom in the
past in having a memento mori on your
desk you know skull
and we're not here for very long and it
behooves us to
to behave and to understand the world
in the most fruitful way for human
fulfillment and happiness and for the
greater fulfillment of whatever it is
that we
sense in in whatever is around us in the
being of the world and
you know the word cosmos keeps coming to
mind which
also in its root means beautiful because
i think what one sees when one looks at
the natural order is that it is
as scientists and mathematicians are
constantly saying
it's outstandingly beautiful complex and
orderly why
where does that come from well i don't
pretend to have an answer
but i see the difference is between
people who think they know the answer
and people who don't i'm one of the
people who don't think they know the
answer so please don't
ask me what the answer is i think i
would disqualify myself from having
anything worthwhile to say
if i thought i had the answer the
difference is not
you hinted at not between atheists on
the one hand and
and um and believers on the other
but it's between fundamentalist
believers
and fundamentalist atheists on the one
hand
and people who often call themselves
honest agnostics on the other
that openness of mind that willingness
to acknowledge that one doesn't know
everything that one's reaching and
searching for something
is far more fruitful and spiritual to me
than saying i know it it's written down
in this book and these are the rules
the i want to go back to the
i listened to all of that and and i want
to go back to the
this co-creation idea because that's
like
that's a that's not a trivial idea
that's
that's an overwhelmingly massive idea
and it see i've
the audience i've talked the audiences
i've talked with
i've i've talked about the necessity of
a vision of life that's sufficiently
demanding meaningful
to justify the trouble of existence
and you it seems to me that
it's necessary psychologically to be in
pursuit of a noble goal
and there isn't a goal that's more noble
than the one that you outlined
virtually by definition right i mean if
if you're co-creating the cosmos
but also if you're in a co-creating
relationship with god
that involves you at the highest level
of being with the structure of being
well i you know again because we're
talking
inevitably in shorthand because this is
why
this book is so colossally long i mean
it's apparently as long as the bible
the reason i had to do that is that i'm
what i'm doing is
is nothing less than this i'm saying the
whole way
in which you are taught by your
education by science
popular science not by
um you know quantum physicists who have
a very much more sophisticated grasp of
philosophy but
by the sort of 19th century mechanists
who still dominate biology unhappily
um a version of some engineering if
you ever liked um this is not a good way
to think
this is not even likely to be
true it doesn't answer to
any aspect of experience of the world
except the most tinyly detailed
so for example what i think is that the
whole structure of things is infinitely
complex and has many recurring loops in
it
and when you try and it just an organism
is like that or even
a cell or even you know part of a cell
an organelle
is amazingly complex the the number of
interactions the number of
chemical reactions that are going on
there is colossal and they all have
cascades that interact with one another
however
if you take from this very large picture
right down to the tiniest tiniest bit of
light
you can see a little chain of arrows
this leads to that leads to that you
can't see that
all kinds of other things going on and
you can identify that and that's what
we're good at doing
and we say if i interfere in that i can
cause something to happen
which might be beneficial for example to
somebody who
has a health condition so i'm not saying
there's anything wrong
with with any of this again i come back
to there's nothing wrong with the left
hemisphere
there's only something wrong with it
when it adopts
the hubristic cloak of knowing
everything
and when you said scientists are not
often heard to
um voice the sort of things that i'm
saying and that you are saying
um i'd like to say that physicists very
often do
but the biologists relatively less often
do now although in the early part of the
century there were many great biologists
such as
jbes haldane his father john scott
haldane conrad howard wallington
um you know ludwig von vertolanti
in austria who who saw a very
sophisticated vision
of the living world of biology but what
happened was
because there were great successes in
molecular engineering
after the war this vision which as i say
is technically correct that you can
interfere as a detail and
do something very valuable but the
mistake is to extrapolate
from that to say this is the structure
of the whole thing we're looking at it's
not it's not like that there are at
least eight or nine ways in which
a living being is not not like a machine
so i am sorry that scientists diminish
themselves by adopting this very narrow
vision
of what life is because after all the
whole point of science the schroedinger
said
is to answer the question who are we and
if it's not answering that question
and it's not assumable into an answer to
that question it's not really
getting us to what the meaning of our
life demands from us that we have
not an answer to the question who are we
not an answer to the question what is
the meaning of life
of course by definition there isn't one
but the very knowledge
that we have to strive for it and not
lose sight of it is very very important
there's a a saying in the midrash you
you are
you're not obliged to finish the work
but you are not
permitted to cease from it and i think
that is i mean i would say that is my
vision of what i do i think it's what
all
seekers after truth have to do whether
they're philosophers or scientists
and you know i would love science to be
more scientific i i
the curious thing is i honor science
deeply
and i think that it has nothing to lose
by making
you know being a little bit humbler than
it is by accepting
that there is a lot that is deeply
puzzling and that the more we know
about physics for example the more we
understand what we don't know
and it's not scientific to rule out
certain ways of thinking to say that
thinking in terms of organic wholes in
terms of
um gestalt gestalt and so forth is
is somehow not scientific no it's just
not the way that a certain very narrow
form of science is practiced and i i
want science
before i die to become more open as
science should be
to be more questing more imaginative you
know in writing this book
i've had a lot to do with the story of
how scientists made their discoveries
how mathematicians made their
discoveries
and they very rarely if ever as george
gaylord simpson himself said you know
one of the great mainstream
um molecular biologists of the last
century
it's very rare that they make them by
following the scientific method
the scientific method is a retrospective
thing that is fitted on to what actually
happens
which is extraordinary insights of
intuition seeing shapes
testing them out of course which is a
scientific method of course
um but it's not this kind of boring
rule-bound thing that it's often made
out to be
well i think with that statement
that's a good place to end for today
it was a nice conclusion um
gone for an hour and a half or so and uh
i appreciate you all right with me very
very much you talking
with me hopefully we can do this again i
want to get further through your book
i'll keep everybody posted as to the
progress of the book and
to where they can obtain it when that
becomes possible
is there anything else that you wanted
to to mention today
that that you want to bring up before we
before we close
well no i i mean i i want to say first
of all
which i haven't really had an
opportunity to say how enormously glad i
am that you are
you know back in debate with us all um
and long may that be um and
i do i think the conversations we have
are good i hope other people may think
that too
um well we're going to put that to the
test
and i'd like to just draw people's
attention to the fact that
in the last six months um which is six
months i think six or seven months
um we've developed something called
channel mcgill chris which is
uh a place on the internet where you can
find out more about my stuff you can see
um talks lectures podcasts things i've
done what i'm you know
and generally keep up to date there's a
forum there where you can enter into and
discuss
my work and there's a place where you
can ask
questions of me so once a month i answer
four questions
out of a list of things that members of
the
because you can either be a non-member
or a member but if you remember you can
ask me
a question which i will then spend
quarter of an hour answering so
you know that that's that's my attempt
to try and
give back something that isn't just you
know the odd book every 10 years so
well we'll make sure that we put the
links and all of that in the description
of this video
and with any luck we'll get a chance to
talk again in the future after we've
both digested this
and this conversation
it was really good to see you again oh
and you thank you
[Music]
you